have you ever felt undesirable do you
feel like you aren't reaching your
potential we're here to help learn how
to be the perfect woman for advice of
totally average man I make 30 to $40,000
a year first step relax and be yourself
men love women who look natural
but don't be afraid of a little color go
on
add a little more you're not a nun be
flirty yeah I'm pretty much an expert in
small boat sailing Wow
not that flirty T's looking a good shake
really learn how to hang out with the
guys but only have female friends
Quinta's single my friend and pretty so
I brought her to increase my value at
the party hey guys don't have male
friends of your own that's weird
mr. poker night don't be afraid to eat
in front of us
a healthy appetite is attractive yeah
don't stuff your face Crouse be funny
but never act funny always laughing his
joke really like your Twitter oh yeah I
heard my latest ones yeah girls and dogs
you feed them you take him out only one
knows where to pee Oh
finally make sure you seem smart but not
smart or bossy or insistent that we
moved to Florida to take care of your
family I actually studied English in
college hey that's cool
if you studied science or math I'd be
intimidated by you there you have it the
perfect woman huh she's not really my
type maybe she was blond and
good-looking or something Honda Civic
I love she's mirrors
I wasn't invited I said no she's not
good